[Music]
5 55 on your wednesday morning might be
the shortest
and sweetest viewer viewer email we've
ever gotten take a look
got the entire email from lyle from
start to finish no editing
people need to maintain their own lane
when making a right turn or left from
traffic signals not crossing over others
right away
it doesn't take two to three lanes to
complete a turn
thank you no anger no bitterness just
matter of fact now
don't get me wrong some of your animated
agitated complaints are equally good
trying to make a point too but since
lyles was so short and sweet
hope you don't mind if we go over this
one more time people need to maintain
their own lane when making a right turn
or left from traffic signals not
crossing over others right away doesn't
take two to three lanes to complete a
turn thank you
so i hope a light bulb goes off for even
one driverless thanks for writing in
buckle up drive carefully please put on
that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com